miss miss Jan sterling is a gifted
actress persuasive and face and figure
in fact a recent issue of an Eastern
magazine actually described her as the
sort of girl who makes a man want to go
home and sawed off his wife's head just
below the ankles
yeah she is with us tonight to make the
awards for question design mister
the costume designer in films is not
limited to creating pretty evening
dresses it's a far more taxing art the
design and the stress all stories with
skill and endless style if that story is
Mary Antoinette the gowns have seemed
decide if it is Robin Hood the tights
must have a heroic flavor even if it's a
dandy the fig leaf must be well tailored
for the color vigor pageantry of its
films Hollywood is much indebted to the
costume designers though is nominated
for the best achievement and costume
design for a black and white production
are all about Eve 20th Century Fox Edith
Head and Charles Lamia born yesterday
Columbia Jean Louie and the Magnificent
Yankee metro-goldwyn-mayer world her
clunker
the winners are Edith Head and child
Vermeer
this is a collaboration of a new studio
department head beetle head had a
costume designer from our city
twentieth century-fox world over
those nominated for the best achievement
and costume design of a color production
are the black rose 20th Century Fox
Michael Whittaker Samson and Delilah
Cecil B DeMille paramon Edith Head
Dorothy Jenkins Ella with Jensen dial
steel and Gwen way clean and that
Forsythe woman metro-goldwyn-mayer
Walter Plunkett and Varys the winner is
Samson and Delilah
the award will be accepted by Gaia Steel
the award is won by five
Jensen guileless feeling when wiggling
mr. Dyle steel accepted the award for
himself and even PM Dorothy Jenkins
Halloween
Jensen and Gwen waiting